qu'on le film arrive le déposant doit
nous donner nous remet un bordereau de
remise de films qu'il a rempli même à
savoir qu'il a manqué d'un petit du film
le réalisateur l'année de réalisation
le numéro de visa le nombre de boîtes et
la nature de l'élément lorsqu'un film
est déposée au cnc c'est entre les mains
d'olivier de ses collègues qu'il arrive
en premier leur service inventaire et
logistique
c'est eux qui vont vérifier le contenu
du produit et s'assurer de sa conformité
nous sommes prêts spécialement chargé de
prendre en charge tous les nouveaux
dépôts ont leur seront ici ou nous avons
aurions le film savoir comme nous
déroulons le film nous regardons le
générique vous remplissez le grès une
grille inventaire des films sont ensuite
inscrits dans la base de données du cnc
est renvoyé vers un espace de stockage
précis ce qu'on appelle nous les boîtes
d'origine
c'est quand le déposant à relax avec ce
soit là mais non les changes
systématiquement on tire une étiquette
mais quelques d'entrée unique est
code-barres on retrouve toutes les
informations là donc un numéro de code
barre se stocker en fonction de la
nature de l'aimant c'est à dire que
toutes les copies vont dans une salle
les négatifs images dans une autre salle
etc etc
ceci pour éviter justement des cas d
accident très guillemets à savoir c'est
pas mal commenté etc
le service ne travaille pas seulement
sur les nouvelles arrivées mais aussi
sur les rétrospectives des archives dans
les années 70 les laboratoires ont
confié de nombreux films au cnc qui
n'ont pas pu être inventoriés à l'époque
olivier doit parfois retrouver l'origine
du film en identifiant les acteurs ou
les décors
un véritable travail d'investigation
dans notre base il ya juste un titre ne
sais pas ce qu'il ya derrière
on ne sait pas si c'est par exemple un
film de fiction un film de non fiction
c'est une copie et c'est donc on demande
à sortir les boîtes regarde ce qu'il ya
dedans et parfois on tombe sur des
trésors ou parfois le film colle la
boîte ne correspond pas à l'élément qui
est acquis at indiqué donc on rétablit
tôt ça et c'est pour la suite direction
le service analyse et gestion
muriel s'occupe des documentaires c'est
elle qui indexe les archives notre
charge à nous en fait c'est de
constituer un catalogue accessible par
les internautes par les différents
publics
qui sont concernés par nos films pour
qu'ils puissent ensuite nous demander à
consulter les films
donc ce sont aussi bien des films de
fiction que des films documentaires
on a des films institutionnels ont
défini scientifique des films de
propagande des films de toutes les
époques
puisque les archives des films des
débuts du cinéma jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc comme vous le voyez c'est très
varié et on ne peut pas s'y retrouver si
on fait pas un catalogage ici les
archives du cnc ne font pas seulement
office d'une grande médiathèque scellé
mais aussi d'un outil de travail pour
les professionnels